exposée pour ne pas oublier au milieu
des étagères de la médiathèque plusieurs
affiches et livre retrace l'histoire de
l'exclavage de sa mise en place à son
abolition en 1848
d'autres travaux mettent en lumière les
acteurs qui ont permis la fin de la
traite des noirs
c'est en fait une exposition qui est
composé de différents personnages qui
ont lutté pour d'autres l'exploitation
contre le racisme pour l'acquisition des
droits civiques et c'est parmi ces
grandes figures des femmes et des hommes
rosa parks célèbre pour sa lutte contre
la ségrégation raciale aux côtés de
martin luther king ou encore victor
schoelcher l'instigateur du décret
abolissant définitivement l'esclavagé en
france on se rend compte que malgré tout
ce qui a été acquis malgré tout ce qui a
été dénoncé et tout ce qui a été
combattue
il ya encore malheureusement énormément
de choses que les gens ne connaissent
pas entraîné ce mal et donc nous avons
besoin de déconstruire ce racisme ces
expositions sont ouvertes à tous elles
favorisent l'image et les textes courts
afin de faciliter la compréhension
auprès des plus jeunes
je pense que
la génération future vraiment besoin de
savoir ce qui s'est vraiment passé
l'ignorance aux commandes il ignorant
c'est vraiment une grosse maladie aussi
qui peut aussi causer aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de garde ses oeuvres occuperont
la médiathèque de voisins-le-bretonneux
jusqu'au 12 mai afin d'honorer le devoir
de mémoire
en 2001 la france est devenue le premier
pays à reconnaître la traite négrière et
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité